بالتزامن ايه مع يومها الوطني بتشهدوا
عمان افتتاح مدينه الطيب النموذجيه
السكنيه في ولايه لواء والتي تبلغ مساحتها
12 مليون متر مربع متضمنه مختلف الخدمات
والمرافق العامه كما تشتمل ايضا على 1300
وحده سكنيه مع قابليه التوسع لتشمل اكثر
من ثلاثه الاف وحده سكنيه مستقبلا مدينه
لواء النموذج النموذجيه في عمان تسوعب نحو
30,000 نسمه وتطبق معايير التخطيط
العمراني
المستدام والحديث
من مسقط نظام الينا موفد العربيه عبد
الرحمن العصيمي عبد الرحمن مساء الخير
مرحبا بك معي في نشره الرابعه من الرياض
اعتذر اولا هي مدينه لواء
لكن خليني اسال عن هذا المشروع يا عبد
الرحمن كيف يبدو الى اين وصلت مراحل
الانجاز في اثره ايضا حتى على قطاع
الاسكان في عمان كيف رصدته
نعم نايف نحن في ولايه لواء بمحافظه شمال
الباطنه في سلطنه عمان في مشروع مدينه
الطيب النموذجيه هذا المشروع الذي
اتى بامر من السلطان الراحل قابوس بن سعيد
للاهالي الذين تضرروا من ميناء صحار كانوا
ساكنين بالقرب من امينه سحر ثم نقلهم الى
هذه المدينه النموذجيه وتعويظهم باراضي لا
تقل الارض عن مساحه 1000 متر الى جانب
ايضا مبلغ تقريبا
75,000 ريال عماني اي ما يعادل خمسه
750,000 ريال سعودي
لمساعدتهم في بناء هذه الاراضي زميلي وليد
ياخذ جوله نحن في احد همم المناطق في هذه
المدينه النموذجيه نشاهد بعض المنازل يتم
بناءها حاليا
وتقريبا على وشك الانتهاء وايضا هناك فلل
تم الانتهاء منها وسكنها الاهالي هذه
المدينه نايف
يعني متكامله من ناحيه البنيه التحتيه
هناك ثمان مدارس موجوده في هذا الحي وهذه
المدينه النموذجيه الى جانب مركز صحي
متكامل ونشاهد ايضا احد المساجد تقريبا 11
مسجدا بها مرافق خاصه مجالس عامه ومنزل
للامام وايضا مدارس تحفيظ القران الكريم
ايضا ما تم تشغيله حتى الان في هذه
المدينه نايف خمس مدارس
وتقريبا المركز الصحي همم يعمل لخدمه
المواطنين الى جانب ايضا سته مساجد همم
هذه المدينه همم تهدف الى الاستدامه
الاجتماعيه وايضا استخدامه البيئيه
والاقتصاديه والمكانيه هذه المدينه ليست
فقط سكنيه ايضا هناك مخططات تجاريه يعني
اذا ما تكلمنا نايف بالنسبه المئويه فهناك
29% من المشروع الاراضي السكنيه
و12% سيتم تخصيصها للمساحات الخضراء
والملاعب وايضا هناك 19% هي معابر الاوديه
لان نشهد وكما نعرف ان عمان عندما تهطل
الامطار بغزاره دائما ما يكون هناك بعض
الاشكاليات بالنسبه للفيضانات
والمشاكل التجمع المياه هناك ايضا حرص على
عدم تكرار مثل هذه المشاكل بالاجان
بالجانب ايضا 17% هي مساحات لمناطق
التطوير المستقبليه وهناك ايضا اثنين
بالمئه من المدينه الى الاراضي السكنيه
عذرا الاراضي الاستثماريه والتجاريه نشاهد
ايضا هذا هو المجلس العام في كل مربع سكني
نايف مجلس عام هذا المجلس هو الاتراح
والافراح بالنسبه للسكان سواء المناسبات
همم الزواجات او ايضا الاعياد ايضا مراسم
العزاء كلها تتم في هذا المجلس العام الذي
هو جزء من ثقافه اهالي السلطنه وايضا همم
حضورهم اجتماعي وبرامجهم الاجتماعيه يعني
مدينه حقيقه نايف متكامله بشكل كبير وايضا
الحكومه العمانيه خلال السنوات القليله
الماضيه حرصت كثيرا على تطوير الاسكان في
السلطنه وتوفير الاسكان والحياه همم
الجيده وتطبيق جوده الحياه بالنسبه
فقط على منطقه الباطنه او مدينه الطيب
النموذجيه الجديده بكل الارقام اللي
ذكرتها قبل قليل عن القطاع في السلطانه
كامله يعني كيف يمكن الحديث عنه او تقييمه
من خلال مشاهده
صحيح نايف يعني لا تخلو ولايه هنا في
سلطنه عمان او مدينه الا وتجد فيها مشروع
سكني متكامل وهناك ايضا حرص من وزاره
الاسكان سواء تسليم الوحدات الجاهزه
للمواطنين او ايضا اعطاء المواطنين
المساحه
واختيار المبنى الذي يريدون ان ان يبنونه
وفق طبعا الكود البنائي الخاص بسلطنه عمان
لكن هناك حرص كبير من الحكومه العمانيه
هنا
لتوفير السكن الملائم للمواطنين همم خاصه
المتزوجين ومن لديه عائله ولديه اطفال
على كل هذه المعلومات والارقام من مسقط
موفد العربيه عبد الرحمن الحسيمه شكرا يا
عبد الرحمن
تنتهي غدا في السعوديه فتره استقبال
طلباتي تملك العقارات من قبل الامانه
العامه لجان ولي النظر في تملك العقارات
احكام وداعه الامانه المستفيدين المتقدمين
بطلبات تملك عبر منصه احكام الى سرعه
استكمال نواقص طلباتهم وفق الشروط
والمتطلبات اللازمه